i have to get to lil nass x
someone who i didn't know existed until
a few days ago
when he engaged in a satanic publicity
campaign
that that i guess sort of worked because
it caught my attention it caught a lot
of other people's
attention lil nass x who is a rapper
is releasing satan shoes 666
individually numbered pairs of nike air
max 97s that were modified by the
company
msc mischief okay i got it
we'll be there they'll be going for over
a thousand dollars beginning march
29th your mind must be truly warped by
the devil if you're willing to pay a
thousand dollars for a pair of running
shoes but
there are other issues at play here
first things first
if you embrace satan who is a real
person
you will burn in hell for eternity hell
which is a real place
we should establish that people are
going to joke about this and say oh here
goes michael he's talking about some
crazy religious stuff i'm not
i'm just bringing you the facts and
facts don't care about your feelings
as my my colleague here loves to say uh
is a real person antonin scalia joked
about this when he was talking to a new
york magazine
interviewer a number of years ago she
was she was mocking him for believing in
the devil he said you know
most people in history have believed in
the devil most of america believes in
the devil
many more intelligent people than you or
i have believed in the devil
so don't do that if you play around with
this stuff even if you think it's funny
uh it's not and you're really putting
yourself in a lot of uh
trouble it's all it's all fun and games
until the devil's eating your soul for
eternity
uh beyond the outrage though is there
something that we can learn
from little nas x is there something
once we once we
tone down the outrage for a second what
is this really saying what can we learn
about this
for our culture i think there's actually
quite a lot there
little nassax is putting out the devil
shoes
that are numbered six six six
you know 666 pairs or a thousand dollars
each they include a drop of human blood
in it
not great um he's doing this in
conjunction with a song that he's
releasing
in which he describes his i guess his
sexual desires turns out he's gay and he
came out and he says he's homosexual
and uh where he's like doing like
jiggling around for the devil and giving
him a lap dance and things like that
so i'm going to tamp down the outrage
for a second and say
nike is denying any involvement with
this it would seem that nike's
nike's statement is that the this
company
mischief along with lil nass x just kind
of bought retail shoes and then
redesigned them
is that true or not i don't know but
nike's saying we don't want anything to
do with this and no matter
how woke your company gets even even a
company like nike it would seem to me
unlikely that
one of their corporate executives
thought yeah i know the way that we're
going to
make a lot of money we're going to
embrace the devil
and put human blood in our shoes eve i
think that's a bridge too far even for
nike
second of all little nas x is not the
first satanist
in entertainment he's not even the first
popular
black entertainer who's embraced
satanism sammy davis jr
one of the great tap dancers and singers
uh famous for the rat pack famous 20th
century entertainer
he was an actual satanist for some time
he eventually left
and he converted to judaism but he
joined the church of satan he actually
he
he even made a sitcom pilot
about satanism called poor devil take a
listen
hello furnace room sami speaking sammy
this is chelsea
hi baby you remember the man that you've
been watching
but why don't you keep insisting as a
hot prospect yeah
well i've got him here on the monitor
and you were right
really he's exactly what you've been
waiting for
can you come up right now oh honey if i
come up there now and lucifer catches me
i'm going to be in all kinds of trouble
oh honey you can't get more trouble than
what you are right now
come on up sammy you're right see you
so it it gets even weirder there's
pentagrams in the show and everything
people people don't forget this they
think about the 50s and the 60s they
think oh you know
that time when america you know it had
all this very bourgeois morality and all
these nice suburbs
and everything and you know america's
most beloved one of america's most
beloved entertainers was a
one-eyed satanist who you know it
still kind of cuts against a lot of what
we're what we're told
it's amazing because we're told it was
an ableist time we're told it was a
racist time
we're told it was an extremely christian
time and yet one of america's most
beloved entertainers
a black one-eyed satanist he eventually
got out of it though
so obviously they're releasing this now
during holy week we're now approaching
easter
little nassax is doing this for
publicity no question
however i watched the video and i think
the video is actually somewhat
interesting
in the video little nassax is
in the garden of eden and then he goes
up to heaven
and then he goes down to hell he
actually glides a stripper pole down to
hell and starts
twerking on satan's face he is not
condemned to hell he freely chooses hell
and even beyond that
we have to realize that in the in the
garden he is depicted as being
tempted by the devil so even that free
choice is conditioned
by sin so you have to ask well how free
was he really
to do it you know you and i we try to
resist temptation and we
fail on and on and on hopefully we get a
little bit better at it but we we still
fail because we're human we have a
broken nature
so it's very interesting here it's not
the judgmental people in heaven
though there are judgmental people
depicted who
force him down to hell he freely chooses
hell
at least in his own mind even though he
has been tempted very clearly by the
devil
is he really free then he gives a lap
dance to satan and then he kills the
devil
and puts the devil's horns on himself
there is nothing new under the sun as
you know and this is not some new work
of art that's come out this is really
in a way it seems to me a hip-hop
modern retelling of paradise lost by
john milton
famous line in paradise lost where the
character of satan is presented in a
sort of sympathetic way
and satan when he's thrust down into
hell
he embraces hell he sort of makes a free
choice for hell
very famous lines he writes farewell
happy fields where joy forever dwells
hail horrors hail infernal world
and thou profoundest hell receive thy
new possessor me satan
one who brings a mind not to be changed
by place or time
the mind is its own place and in itself
can make a heaven of hell a hell
of heaven what matter where if i be
still the same
and what i should be all but less than
he whom thunder
hath made greater god here at least
we shall be free the almighty
hath not built here for his envy
will not thrive us hence here we may
reign secure and in my choice
to reign is worth ambition though in
hell
there is a lot here i think actually the
little nass music video
makes a lot of sense in our present
political climate especially with what
the left is pushing
but even with what some portions of the
right is pushing
one of the more provocative elements in
milton's paradise lost
is that satan reads kind of like what
you might call a
classical liberal at least in the way
that sort of
we understand that term now he reads as
a guy who
who values his will and his ambition and
his
choice even if he thinks it's a free
choice but maybe it's not a totally free
choice
he values that over what is true
and what is good and what is actually
beautiful he says well i've got my mind
so i can make a hell of heaven or heaven
of hell me me me i'm gonna choose it
the reality doesn't really matter it's
just my mind my will my desires my
appetite
that's what matters this is sure you can
have this as a logical conclusion of
leftism
you can have this as a logical
conclusion of individualism too it's why
you're seeing this right now
sort of collapsing on the right the the
of the last 10 or 20 years
it's become fashionable to reduce all of
conservative thought to
i want to do whatever i want to do and i
want to follow whatever desires i want
and darn it that's my right that's
freedom that's not real freedom
none of the serious thinkers about
freedom liberty have
ever thought that certainly our founding
fathers didn't think that there is a
difference between liberty and
licentiousness
you cannot really make
heaven into hell or hell into heaven but
your mind can become
so perverted and so self-obsessed and so
prideful
that you would prefer that you would
feel heaven to be hell
because if i had disordered your desires
and your your
perception has become that is the risk
that we're in for society right now it's
why i think actually this little nas
video which is
satanic you know so don't it's bad i'm
not not encouraging it but but it's why
it actually does have something
rather interesting to say about our
politics and hopefully
through providence we can evil things
can can be turned
toward good uh hopefully we can we can
learn some lessons from this
terrible video especially during holy
week it's why it was released
we sing the easter anti-antiphon we sing
o happy
fault that won for us so great so
glorious a redeemer christians celebrate
even the fall of mankind which was
which was evil and bad in and of itself
but god turns it to good
and it gives us our great and glorious
redeemer so that's why
we call it a happy fault perhaps we can
we can see these things
that can be turned to good and take the
that that good turn
uh when we can find it if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]